tous les égouts de montréal convergent
ici dans cette usine d'épuration de
rivière des prairies à l'intérieur de
cet immense cylindre des puis plonge à
près de 50 mètres pour collecter les
eaux usées à période de fortes pluies on
va traiter jusqu'à 84 mètres que par
seconde donc c'est 23 stades à l'épée
mais le traitement actuel et la
décantation ne permettent pas de
désinfecter l'eau on y retrouve des
résidus de médicaments des molécules qui
perturbent le système hormonal toutes
sortes de contaminants qui sont tous un
peu plus inquiétant les uns que les eaux
de nos mesures on évalue que la station
d'épuration sans traitement actuellement
pour les continents émergents relâche
une tonne de molécules actives
d'antibiotiques dans le fleuve par année
la ville octroie à la firme pomerleau le
premier de huit contrats pour la
construction du site d'ozonation c'est
le projet environnemental tu verrais le
plus significatif des 30 dernières
années au québec le gaz sera injecté
dans ces deux canaux juste avant que
l'eau ne retourne au fleuve pour éviter
que l'ozone dans l'air qui aura pas été
en contact avec l'eau se retrouvent dans
l'atmosphère
on doit quand ceux des grosses cif en un
sur chaque canal qui seront donc hors
d'usagé chacun leur tour pendant six
mois lors des deux prochains hivers
conséquences lusine verra sa capacité
maximale baissé de 30% des surverses
direct dans le fleuve sont donc à
prévoir 35% des eaux usées 65% d'autres
pluies et ça va être pour de très
courtes périodes de temps un peu comme
on a c'est ainsi quand il ya des grandes
pluies on a des déversements et c'est un
moindre mal pour être en avance sur son
temps selon cet expert des normes sur
l'abattement des micropolluants comme
les médicaments ça existe présentement
au canada donc la ville de montréal va
traiter ses eaux usées
mais les normes sont sont encore à venir
une petite unité pilote qui sera
pleinement en fonction d'ici trois mois
permet d'ajuster le procédé comme on
accepte des molécules s'est passé si on
perd son âme et pas assez par exemple de
faire une oxydation partiel puis surtout
et avec des sous produits qui peuvent
être
quinze années de développement mais
aussi des ces erreurs ont fait tripler
les coûts de ce projet pour atteindre
700 millions de dollars il sera de loin
le plus important au monde ici mathieu
prost radio canada montréal